now we are joined in the studio by two
of the most famous people behind one of
the most popular shows on television the
walking dead it follows a group of
survivors after a zombie apocalypse and
it's won awards for both the action and
the special effects and is currently
midway through its seventh series a very
warm welcome this morning to Norman
Reedus of course plays Daryl in the show
and we're joined also by the executive
producer Greg Nicotero a very good
morning to you both and I have to say
I've already had a tweet from one of
your 3.4 million Twitter followers this
morning saying please please please do
not let Daryl get killed off in this
season we wife and daughter couldn't
cope and and that just kind of is
testament to how your character has
evolved from this kind of slightly
awkward character in the beginning to
this now really popular central
character you talk about slightly
awkward what do you kind of say I'm not
you're acting just the character no no
he's super already kidding um I mean we
have a good group down there and um you
know everything all the storylines like
everyone gets excited when scripts come
out and you know that and it's been it's
not like a movie where you know you
haven't you know a month to do a
character or something but to have
several years all the little things you
do all add up and it's it's quite a
blessing now there was time with a
character should we take a look then at
this rate to season for anyone that
hasn't seen it where have you been let's
have another look now we need the
Kingdom
you got to make that happen
sorry I mean I'm gonna I really am but
uh it can't be me look whatever it is
you're holding on to it's already gone
man wake the hell up okay and Greg I
have to ask about that the zombie
apocalypse as a genre how is why is this
struck such a chord been so popular
because this there's been so many films
about zombies coming to you know eat the
living and things like that why is this
struck such a chord amongst viewers well
I think a lot of it has to do with
primal fears and what people are afraid
of I've been a fan of the zombie genre
since nine living-dead what makes the
Walking Dead different is the ensemble
cast
you know this cast that was put together
seven years ago there's something for
everyone to identify with the characters
are great you love Darrell you love
Carol you love Rick you can identify
with them so you're instantly pulled
into that sort of struggle by finding
people
you don't think Norman was saying we've
had 99 episodes to get to know these
characters and get to know these people
and it and it resounds with the audience
and for me you know doing special
effects for for all these years I love I
love the gore I love the challenge of
every episode coming up with something a
little different and unique and keeping
it fresh if you can say fresh in terms
of zombie world yeah
I wanted to ask because obviously Greg
is the sort of special-effects guru as
an actor how challenging is it sometimes
when you're seeing those scripts and
you're reading through it you're
thinking wow you know the special
effects involved in the scene are going
to be mind-blowing I mean Greg and his
team constantly surprise us with just
the most disgusting awesome surreal
stuff all the time yeah um you know it's
it's we've had actors like almost throw
up playing a scene because it's so
gnarly um but I mean they constantly
find new ways
to do this I mean every year we say you
know it's it's it's ramped up our
zombies or there's a new level of them
and and we say it every year and we mean
it of you because he they bring that to
the day one speaking of that some people
thought the level of violence in the
season premiere went too far what do you
make of that well it was a brutal
storyline it's a brutal time in our show
and it serves our it serves the story
that we're telling it would do the story
a disservice to not allow our viewers to
feel what the characters are feeling it
and the first half of the season really
did take us into some deep dark places
you know you see Daryl broken you see
Rick broken you're watching your heroes
ground into the dirt and it's a really
uncomfortable scenario to experience but
the second half of the season we get a
lot of Redemption and we see that Daryl
has escaped from the sanctuary and Rick
has decided to fight so everything that
we set up on the first half of the
season now our momentum is taking us
towards a much different place people
like yeah there's the Daryl I love
that's the Rick I love this is gonna be
great they're going to get back together
and kick some butt so also it's a
testament to Steven Yeun and Michael
Cudlitz for making those characters so
lovable that people freak out when
they're gone yeah and it's and it's
interesting for us to on the set you
know we've worked seven years with
Steven and in five years and you feel
that loss when they're gone
you know I mean I'm kind of I feel a
little responsible because I've killed
half of your characters on the show one
night I called Melissa McBride just to
say hello she's like what why you
calling me what's happening no I just
you worry you do yeah you
you're always anytime I call into the
back line
not like vehicle and I suppose lots of
people hoping that this will run on and
on there's a what rumors of an eighth
series in the pipeline some people
saying it could go as far as 12 series
because if the material in those comic
books how far you can push it how many
more people can you kill off well you
know it's a compelling story and that's
really what it's about when it's time to
run the story wraps up the story wraps
up but we have a lot of material to
cover and you know we have a lot of
great actors half of them that are from
here you're the only person it's not
from the UK literally kind of yeah right
because with with Lennie and Andy and
Tom Payne yeah absolutely
half the people don't even know that
they're there Brits until off Cameron
with Andy he he keeps his American
southern accent well even when we're not
filming so from April to November he
never drops that's the easiest way to
keep an accent and we could talk all day
it's so interesting to talk to both of
you at Norman Reedus Greg McAteer thanks
so much for coming in so early as well
really appreciate it thank you
thank you lots more still to come after
this short break